father is charged with murder after
police say that he beat a man to death
who was reportedly trying to go into the
bathroom stall that his daughter was in
Melvin Harris is accused of killing Leon
Armstrong earlier this month at a quick
trip convenience store in Phoenix Carter
Evans spoke to both families including
the suspects daughter Carter good
morning good morning
earlier this month Melvin Harris and his
teenage daughter visited this
convenience store so she could use the
restroom it was just before midnight and
it was just supposed to be a brief stop
but it ended in a deadly fight right
here outside the parking lot what do you
think your dad was doing that night
protecting me
Melvin Harris his 16 year old daughter
says she regrets telling her father what
happened inside this Phoenix QuikTrip
convenience store on August 2nd her
mother asked that we not disclosed the
teens name no one's coming at me like I
did something to him
according to court records inside the
store a man entered the woman's restroom
and tried to get into her closed and
lock stall door shortly after the teen
told her dad what happened Harris
alerted a security guard to quote take
care of the situation or he would do it
himself security told him they would
handle the situation oh yeah we don't
play that that's the third time he did
that we're gonna act him up if you don't
do it
Harris later allegedly approached the
man outside the QT where he punched him
in the face causing the victim to fall
then struck the victim in the face
several more times and also kicked and
stomped on him 26 year-old Leon
Armstrong died I don't think anybody can
be prepared to hear that type of news
that someone just was so cruel
Armstrong's aunt Kathleen a Johnson says
he suffered from schizophrenia though he
did have some mental illness he was
never a person that was considered a
pedophile of any sort Harris is now
facing a charge for second-degree murder
Diana Jackson is his fiancee akai died
here
yeah I mean this is really serious
because nobody should have died she's
supposed to be able to go in there use
the restroom we go to our fountain drink
and go home now a spokesperson for Kwik
Trip says that this is a horrible
tragedy and they're gonna continue to
assist police we reached out to the
security company that operates here
we've not heard back
Harris points out that he did not throw
the first punch that's his claim but
police say in this case that doesn't
matter
JOHN CARTER thank you